for more information on tutoring or how
to support move university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
so in the previous video we mentioned
that the square of a wave function size
squared is equal to the electrons
probability density which is the
likelihood that we find as an electron
in a certain region of space so in this
video we're going to draw them
specifically for hydrogen's 1s orbital
now this 1s might not make sense quite
yet if you're aren't familiar with it if
you are familiar with 1s being is cool
but if not that'll kind of be explained
later so if you come back to this video
after you know what s orbital is then
that might be a little bit helpful in
sort of allowing your knowledge and
understanding to come full circle but if
you don't know what it is right now it's
not too too important ok so the idea is
that if we imagine an atom in 3d space
right and we can define it by or imagine
it at least by the 3d axis where we have
an x axis y axis and a z axis so we got
three dimensions here and this here
what's drawn is the probability density
the electron probability density so if
we think about the origin the
intersection point of the x y&z axes as
you know the center and specifically as
the nucleus then this sort of everything
in blue here is kind of sort of showing
UV they likelihood that an electron
would was we're sort of the electron
would be around that nucleus so you can
see that where the blue is really really
dense and and where you see most of the
blue is near the nucleus or near the
center right so as you sort of move away
though these dots that represent the
probability that an electron will kind
of be there they become less and less
frequent becomes less and less densely
packed so as you increase in distance
away though some distance we call our
right as you move further and further
away the likelihood that you would find
an electron at that certain point or at
that certain point as you move further
and further away becomes lower right so
as our increases the probability density
decreases which means that you're less
likely to find an electron further away
from the nucleus and that makes sense
right for thinking about hydrogen's
Oh thinking about hydrogen it's got one
proton and one electron so the electron
is attracted to the proton at the
nucleus right that the protons in the
nucleus its positively charged electrons
floating somewhere around it it makes
sense that it would most likely be as
close as it can be to that nucleus right
because they're attracted the opposite
charges attract
so the probability density here if we
graph the probability density versus the
distance from the nucleus that looks
like this
something like that so what does this
mean well at really really tiny
distances away from the nucleus so like
here and here and here the probability
density is really really high right we
got tons and billa the likelihood that
an electron would be super super close
to the nucleus is really high but as you
move further and further away as the R
value gets bigger the probability
density decreases it decreases in
decreases it decreases and the value of
the probability density as the R gets
really really big becomes smaller and
smaller and smaller partially the
probability density gets smaller and
small and smaller as the R value
continues to get big but this value here
approaches 0 the probability density
approaches 0 but it never actually hits
0 ok so what does that mean ok let's see
let's reveal what's written here quite a
bit of stuff ok so this says the farther
a given point is from the nucleus the
less likely it is that an electron will
be at that point ok that makes sense
given what we just said up here all
right
further away less likely to find an
electron there cool the fact that the
distance can increase infinitely
resulting in a smaller and smaller
probability but not a 0 probability
means that an electron can be infinitely
far away from the nucleus that means an
atom size is infinite I put fish in
finish I even put lol it's pretty funny
anyway the point is that the atom size
is can't really entirely be defined if
this if this probability is it doesn't
actually hit 0 right there's no actual
like explicit limit so because of this
it's it's kind of it but you can't
define the atom size if you include the
entire probability density because you
can't include the entire probability
density so because of this we scientists
kind of say that the atom size includes
around 90 to 95% I think maybe some
people will pick a certain value so I
might say
five or ninety some might say 95 but the
point is that there's the atom size is
sort of taken to be around 90 or 95% of
the probability density to include 90 to
95% of the probability that's because we
can't include all hundred-percent right
so so that's how the atom size is sort
of looked at now there's another way to
think about probability density and that
is radial probability density okay so
what is that so that's not just size
squared it's 4 PI R squared sighs
squared
but what this is the radial probability
density is the total probability of
finding an electron at some particular
distance R away from the nucleus so it's
not just the probability of finding an
electron at a certain point that's our
our distance away but the total
probability of finding electron within
that distance R away so let's kind of
visualize this by putting little rings
around this nucleus that represents
spheres that that encompass all of the
the space at that distance R so if we
imagine a bunch of different rings here
and each of these rings represent some
distance R and all the area or volume
sort of bound by each of these rings so
as you move further and further away
we've got different R values here right
like this this would be that's kind of
hard to see but if we have an R value
maybe here like this R value R 1 versus
the vs. this R to right or even further
away than R 3 the radial probability
density sort of describes the total
probability of finding an electron
within that space down bound by that
that distance or that radius R ok so
simply how can we put this in simple
terms it's basically if we think about
these different rings by making sort of
spheres around the nucleus it's
basically asking the question which
sphere is most densely packed with
electrons so what happens here is that
for us for a while as you increase are
you're including more and more of the
probability density so
it the the radial probability density
will increase but it'll only increase up
into a certain point where the radial
probability density is maximum and it
will drop back down and approach zero
like like it did before with the
probability density and the reason why
is because at a certain point your R is
going to be so far away that most of
what you're talking about within that
space is just empty and the probability
density is really really low as you get
further and further away so the radial
probability density includes more empty
space and less densely packed spit or
less electron densely packed space right
so the idea here is that there's a
certain distance R R sub e to the
negative a negative or R of the electron
and that is the distance from the
nucleus where an electron is most likely
to be you know in that region right or
an electron that's the distance from the
nucleus where an electron is most likely
to be now for a hydrogen that value is
0.5 to 9 angstroms
right or 5.2 9 times 10 to the negative
11 meters now this value was actually
Bohr's orbit distance from the nucleus
and Bohr so the board was kind of on to
something but the issue with what Bohr
said is that Bohr said that the electron
orbited at this distance away from the
nucleus all the time right whereas the
quantum mechanical model says that
that's where the electron spends most of
its time okay so I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying